jedes Jahr 400.000 neue Wohnungen das
hat sich ihre Regierung als Ziel gesetzt
Koalitionsvertrag wo stehen wir da
aktuell wir sind völlig zu Recht wie von
ihnen formuliert in einer wohnkrise
nichtsdestotrotz brauchen wir diese
400.000 Wohnungen ist ja keine Zahl die
man sich so jetzt 400.000 war
vorgenommen jedes Jahr die Situation ist
nicht gut das weiß jeder wir sind ich
weiß nicht die aktuellen Zahlen bei
250.000 50 also weiter von entfernen die
4000 zu erreichen was ja eigentlich nur
zur Folge hat dass die Politik noch sehr
viel stärker agieren muss um diese
400000 zu erreichen weil das keine Zahl
ist die man sich auswürfelt sondern das
ist der minimale Bedarf die wird jedes
Jahr brauchen deswegen ist es ja nicht
unerheblich das genau auch zu wissen wo
wir aktuell stehen wenn sie sagen so
über einen Daumen geeilt sind wir da
150.000 etwa der hinterher das war ein
Versprechen dass auch sie mit abgegeben
haben deswegen arbeiten wir auch jeden
Tag in der Ampel daran wir treiben das
baumministerium will erwarten dass mehr
passiert wir haben als FDP-Fraktion noch
eigenes Papier vorgelegt mit 11 schnell
zu ergreifenden Maßnahmen zum Beispiel
ein Dachausbau fördern Bürokratie
abbauen auch das ein oder andere im
förderdings
wir brauchen den Content dass wir diese
Wohnungen bauen und dann müssen auch die
Grünen einschlagen wenn wir die Wohnung
nicht bauen das ist können bevor Sie
anfangen zu regieren Herr wählt jetzt
sitzt hier der mit am Tisch der das mit
seiner Regierung vertritt dieses
Versprechen 400.000 neue Wohnungen jetzt
hör mal liegt wieder weiter hinter
zurück und er sagt wir arbeiten daran
dass es dahin kommt das bedeutet ja man
muss jetzt die Folgejahre ja drei ja
vier 600.000 700.000 schaffen um das
überhaupt wieder aufzuholen was denken
glauben Sie unsere Zuschauer was denken
die Mieter in dem Moment die
möglicherweise in diese Wohnung hätten
einziehen können also erstmal kann ich
jeder Mietern jede neue Wohnung
einziehen das ist eine ganz wichtige
Informationen weil die Wohnung die
geschaffen werden sind ja nur begrenzt
für breite Schichten der Bevölkerung
auch bezahlbar das heißt Luxuswohnung
teure Wohnungen sind große Wohnungen der
der Anteil der preisgünstigen Wohnung
liegt bei ungefähr 15% in der Regel das
von Kommune zu Kommune etwas
unterschiedlich ich halte das für
Fiktionen solche Zahlen in die Welt zu
setzen natürlich konnte keiner wissen
dass wir den Ukraine Krieg haben und das
konnte auch keiner schon die Inflation
in baukostenanstieg vorhersagen aber
400.000 Wohnungen war auch ohne diese
Geschichte eine riesig ehrgeizige Ziel
und aus meiner Sicht in dieser Summe für
die Bevölkerung die am ehesten auf
Wohnung angewiesen ist auch gar nicht
notwendig sage ich ganz ehrlich uns
kommt es darauf an vor allen Dingen
preisgünstigen Wohnungsbau zu errichten
weil diese Menschen am Markt sich ebenso
gut nicht bedienen können während
Familien oder Haushalte mit höheren
Einkommen in der Regel auch etwas finden
wenn sie durch Berlin gehen
beispielsweise dann finden sie teilweise
Quartiere wo wenn sie da mal am
Wochenende sind am Samstag keine
einziges Lichtlein brennt weil viele
ihre Zeit oder dritt Wohnungen hier
haben da gibt da wird auch ziemlich viel
Unsinn gebaut deswegen aus unserer Sicht
müssen wir auch im Hinblick auf den
Klimaschutz ist ja auch eine Aufgabe der
Bundesregierung sehr wohl aufpassen was
wir mit der Bauindustrie machen und da
meine ich müssen wir er uns
konzentrieren konzentrieren auf die
wichtigen Sachen das diskutieren wir
gleich ein Bild lassen jetzt einmal bei
diesen 400.000 bleiben wo sie jetzt
sagen ist vielleicht gar nicht so
wichtig weil nur ein kleiner Teil davon
hätte wirklich der breiten Masse der
Bevölkerung der den den Menschen die
nicht
Luxuswohnung suchen geholfen wie viele
Menschen gerade in diesen niedrigeren
mittleren Einkommen suchen aktuell
wohnen also wir schätzen den äh
jährlichen Bedarf auf 150 bis 100 bis
200.000 an diesen Wohnungen die für
breite Schichten der Bevölkerung
beziehbar wären das haben wir schon
erreicht wenn man so will 250.000
Wohnungen aber die Wohnung die errichtet
worden sind die sind eben nicht
verbreite Schichten der Bevölkerung
sondern wir haben zum Beispiel im
sozialen Wohnungsbau ich glaube 27.000
Wohnungen in 2021 errichten lassen das
sind natürlich Haushalte mit geringem
Einkommen und das sicher zu wenig und wo
fehlt da besonders also nur in den
Großstädten oder trifft sie Fläche in
das Problem ist weniger die regionale
Verortung na klar es ist vor allen
Dingen da wo die Nachfrage hoch ist da
brauchen wir die Wohnung das gar keine
Frage aber also
Universitäten
aber eins ist auf jeden Fall klar was
wir dafür brauchen für diesen
Wohnungsbau sind ja Grundstücke das ist
die erste Klammer sozusagen die gelöst
werden muss und da haben wir ein Problem
nehmen Sie Berlin innerhalb des S-Bahn
Ringes wo die Nachfrage besonders hoch
ist sind ganze 11 % in öffentliche Hand
das ist ein Problem weil sozialen
Wohnungsbau kann man auf diesen privaten
Grundstücken nur dann errichten wenn wir
in solchen Kooperation baulandmodell
Vereinbarung mit privaten Treffen die
ein Teil soziale Wohnungsbau errichten
sonst kommen wir überhaupt nicht zum
sozialwohnungsbau das ist ein zentrales
Problem also wo sind die Grundstücke wie
können die Kommunen die Grundstücke
bereithalten das sind ihre viele Fehler
gemacht worden machen sie sich das in
ihrem politischen Alltag vielleicht
nicht ausreichen und bewusst was es
bedeutet bedeutet Wohnungsnot zu haben
ey natürlich ich bin übrigens aus der
Familienpolitik zur Wohnungspolitik
gekommen weil ich mir nicht mehr
erklären konnte wie sich Familien in
großen Städten des wohnen leisten können
die Wohnkosten sind massiver massiver
Triebfeder in der Ampel ich muss leider
ein paar Sachen korrigieren es tut mir
leid die Bedarf 150.000 im Jahr ist viel
zu niedrig die Wissenschaft geht von 400
bis 700.000 aus plus das was wir
brauchen für die Flüchtlinge also wir
müssen diesen Wohnraum schaffen
natürlich muss er günstig sein aber auch
der Begriff wir brauchen dafür ein
freies Grundstück auf den wir irgendwas
bauen ist auch veraltet wir müssen es
Bau Potential schöpfen Umbau Ausbau
daraufstockung Umnutzung muss ein Hotel
immer Hotel sein oder kann es auch ein
Studentenwohnheim sein wir müssen
wegkommen von der Vorstellung eine
Wohnung kann nur auf eine grünen Fläche
entstehen wir müssen schauen was für
Potenzial es gibt und da gibt es in der
Dach Aufstockung alleine in Deutschland
laut Wissenschaft bis zu 1 Million
Wohnungen Potenzial und die zu heben da
bin ich dabei das ist Aufgabe der
Regierung die Regelungsrahmen zu setzen
und das machen wir
Vertrauen so viel wie niemand anderes
hier bei uns am Tisch das ist nämlich
ihr Job für Condor Wessels sie bauen
bauen bauen aber sie bauen zu wenig
warum
wir bauen sicher noch nicht zu wenig
aber wir könnten die Zahlen die hier
aufgerufen werden als Bauindustrie gerne
bauen wir wollen die Wohnung gerne bauen
wir wollen
kostengünstige Wohnungen also die
150.000 von den Herr wild spricht sind
ja kostengünstige Wohnung was ist eine
kostengünstige Wohnung da
kostengünstliche Wohnung sind sind
mieten für für mich die oder wo die
wohnungsbaukosten Herstellkosten um die
3000 € pro Quadratmeter Wohnfläche
liegen das ist heute der Preis für eine
kostengünstige Wohnung ein Jahr zurück
was 1000 € weniger es muss man sagen da
waren die Kosten günstigen Wohnung für
2000 € zu bauen die kann man bauen die
kann man auf Grundstücken bauen die
natürlich die Kommunen zur Verfügung
stellen sollten und dann kriegen auch
die Kunden von Herrn wild oder die
die sie vertreten er will die kriegen
dann auch ihre Wohnung die
preisgünstigen aber wenn die Kommunen
weiterhin von uns verlangen 30 Prozent
Sozialwohnungen für sechs Euro 50 zu
bauen das halten wir nicht aus weil
einer übersetzt für das was wir
eigentlich brauchen in der Stadt
speziell in Berlin bezahlbare Mieten da
sagen sie das lohnt sich einfach für uns
überhaupt gar nicht diese Wohnung dazu
mieten haben für uns lohnt sich diese
Wohnung zu bauen und wir verdienen
insofern ja nicht weil wir nicht die
Wohnungsbaugesellschaften sind dies
vermieden sondern wir sind die
Bauindustrie dies baut und wir können
Neubau zu erträglichen Preisen
Grundstückspreisen für 12 bis 14 € in
dieser Stadt vermieten das ist einfach
die die die Tatsache und wir kriegen ja
weiterhin als herstellende
Wohnungswirtschaft
Daseinsvorsorge des Staates auch für
bürdet wir müssen 80 000 € pro Stunde
Stellplatz bezahlen wir müssen
kindergartenstellplätze ablesen wir
müssen Artenschutz um
Investitionen tätigen wir müssen
Ersatzpflanzungen vornehmen warum muss
man das tun wenn man günstige Wohnungen
haben will wenn man den Fokus auf
absolut kostengünstigen Wohnungsbau der
Verantwortlichen
absolute
Bürokratieabbau Partei und jetzt das
also nicht nicht alles was
Regelungsrahmen ist ist auf Bundesebene
geregelt aber es ist schon richtig wir
haben verlernt günstig zu bauen weil wir
ständig neue Anforderungen machen die
Kommune liegt noch was oben drauf dann
liegt das Land oder was oben drauf und
dann liegt erhabe noch was oben drauf
wir müssen wieder zurückkommen dass wir
günstig bauen weil wir günstig baut kann
auch günstiger vermieten tatsächlich
sind manche externe Schocks die kann die
Politik auch nicht heilen also die
Energiekosten sind ein Problem auf wenn
wir gegen arbeiten die werden auch
wieder nachlassen die Lieferketten der
kriegt das was verteuert wurde da können
wir auch politisch nicht gegensteuern
aber was wir machen müssen und auch
können und das auch die Debatte die wir
Kommunion führen wir müssen bauen
günstiger machen einfach machen und
schneller machen Digitalisierung des
Bauens der Antrag dauert heute oft
länger als der Baumaßnahme wie absurd
ist das eine neue Erkenntnis Herr Bäcker
oder ist das genau das Thema über das
wir eigentlich seit 30 40 Jahren
streiten in Deutschland absolut also das
ist überhaupt nichts Neues ich bin jetzt
seit ca 10 Jahren in allen möglichen
baukostensenkungskommission Bezeichnung
auch mit Herrn wild immer zusammen wir
bespielen die gleichen Protagonisten mit
unterschiedlichen parteilichen Farben
die uns da begleiten aber die Dinge die
zum günstigen bauen für diese waren vor
10 Jahren genau die gleichen dieser die
heute sind und reden über diese Themen
und keiner löste
Regelung der regelungswahn der Politik
immer wieder
dämmstoffbomber zu bauen wir nennen
dämmstoffröhre immer effektiver immer
immer weniger CO2 natürlichen Heere Ziel
wunderbar wir unterstützen durch alle
damit wir mehr einbauen dürfen in die
Häuser dafür machen wir mehr Umsatz als
Baufirmen das ist so einfach aber die
Dinge
sie profitieren sogar noch von Teilen
der Bürokratie ärgern sich zwar weil
alles länger dauert am Ende machen sie
beim Teil ihres Profils damit also ein
System das unter untereinander ganz gut
funktioniert aber keines der Probleme im
Land oder muss man überhaupt
das ist einfach wenn wir an einer Stelle
ein Haus bauen mit mir Anforderungen
denn bauen wir natürlich lieber mit mehr
Anforderungen als mit weniger
Anforderungen aber wir können sehr gut
mit weniger Anforderungen bauen aber wir
dürfen es nicht würden sie abgezockt
oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie